we just hit 20 million subscribers on
this channel and I am incredibly
grateful and I'm so proud of each and
every one of you for joining me on this
amazing journey but before we get
started with the celebrations I have to
tell you about a year ago on a charity
livestream I promised that if we hit 20
million subscribers I would release my
tasteful but I am a man of my word and
available right now for pre-order is my
tasteful nudes calendar chock full of 12
different compromising images that I
never thought would ever make their way
to the Internet let alone be sold in a
calendar set and I'm very positive that
my mom is not going to be proud of me
after this video comes out now a few
things about this calendar it's only
available for the next 48 hours but if
you order within those 48 hours I will
personally hand sign every single
calendar that is ordered and not only
that but all the proceeds that I would
get from these calendars will be donated
directly to the Cancer Research
Institute and in addition to that this
calendar is special because it's not
just pictures of me but it's also
pictures of your favorite egos like dark
applier the gyms and a few other
surprises that you'll just have to wait
and see I know this is probably the
weirdest celebration that anyone has
ever done for a subscriber milestone let
alone one as important as 20 million
which is something I never ever ever
thought that my channel would ever get
to but but I should mention that this
this calendar while I am yes naked in
the pictures it's no worse than like the
ESPN Body Issue which if you don't know
what that is it's where they take a
bunch of athletes and they they pose
them and they're naked but you don't
actually see any so both you're welcome
and sorry to disappoint but my dick is
not
they're tasteful it's tasteful nudes
so there's tasteful censorship it's just
it's like it's like just convenient
censorship it's basically it amounts to
pg-13 nudity which means that nothing's
actually shown it's just implied but
this was a lot of fun to make actually
really proud of it you guys should check
it out the link is in the description
below remember it's only available for
the next 48 hours starting at the time
that this video was released so if you
don't get it now it'll never be
available again so go click the link in
the description below it benefits a
great charity it's a really cool thing
and I will sign every calendar that's
ordered so you will get something that's
personally signed from me I don't care
how many are ordered I will sign every
single one now that may mean that it'll
take more time to get to you but I think
it'll be worth it if it gets money to a
great loss so with that being said I
wanted to take a moment to really thank
you guys from the bottom of my heart I
really do appreciate you guys being with
me on this journey it's been just about
six years now that I've been doing
YouTube and that's not a long time in
the grand scheme of things but these
past six years have been so full of life
and so full of love and so full of
memories that I'll never forget both
good and bad but predominantly good and
it's good because you guys are here and
you guys support me through all of this
and you guys do so much for me and I'm
so happy to be able to provide
entertainment for you to provide like
reassurance for you when you need it and
to provide encouragement when you when
you don't feel it and you know it's it's
something that I never ever thought
would grow to this level I've said it a
million times and I'll say it a million
times more but thank you from the bottom
of my heart thank you so much for being
with me for encouraging me when I needed
it the most
for being there when I didn't feel like
I was up to the task
you know this this channel works both
ways I try to encourage you guys but you
guys encouraged me so much more than you
could ever know I love seeing what you
make
I love seeing all the creativity that's
poured out of the community
I love seeing everything that you do I
love seeing people in the community rise
and find success of their own because
you can that's the beautiful thing like
what I do here is not all that special I
may work hard and I may try really hard
to make it the best that I can make it
but anyone can do that
any of you guys can do that any of you
guys can pursue your dreams and they may
not be YouTube they may not be artistic
endeavors but whatever you put your mind
to if you work hard enough and you rally
people to your cause if you reach out to
the community and you try to help as
much as they try to help you anything's
possible
so thank you so much for being with me
for twenty million subscribers thank you
for supporting me through these tasteful
nude calendars and thank you for
believing in the charitable efforts that
I do and the weird ways that I try to
raise money for charity just thank you
it means the world to me so thank you
all so much for watching check out the
tasteful nudes calendar in the link in
the description below and remember I'll
hand signing each one it's only
available for about 48 hours and no dick
so thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye